suspendu l'offre de tamise en hiver donc
du fait de devenir une star du jour au
lendemain tu parles de ta longue et
douloureuse descente aux enfers tu as
connu une sévère dépression c'est oui
voilà là ça va beaucoup mieux ou pas pas
tout à fait oui tu parles aussi tu
parles aussi à un moment qui est
choquant même tu parles aussi voilà de
deux tons la drogue examen sur et ça ça
c'est un témoin pour moi c'est le
passage le plus fort du livre mais parce
que j'ai revers vie parce que j'ai fait
comme enfin la bêtise de faire un peu
comme tout le monde peut faire comme au
far avec moult amis c'est en fait
j'avais j'ai voulu marquer peut-être
avec autant de franchise et de précision
parce que voilà justement c'est ne
souhaite pas ça parce que après je
marque vraiment comment c'est compliqué
de s'en sortir
donc voilà non mais de faire passer mes
chéris on n'a pas besoin de ça pour
s'amuser je vous le dis mais ne faites
pas comme les autres ça sert à rien
c'est pour ça que maintenant je n'ai pas
été très loin quoi là dedans voilà je
suis passé dans beaucoup de dérives
beaucoup dead 2 pourquoi il faut nous
dit moi j'ai l'alcool les médicaments la
drogue on va dire que je ne m'en vante
pas j'ai lu et relu de santé mieux grâce
à ça je croyais que je me sentais mais
je crois qu'on avait besoin de quelque
chose maintenant ou 17 ans je peux dire
qu'on n'est bien sans rien voilà donc
tous les jeunes qui nous regardent
olivier magne âge c'est ça vraiment je
vous le jure moi je suis le plus agité
du monde vraiment je suis le mec qui
rigole plus je n'ai jamais rien plus
tard heureusement parce que déjà dans
l'état où vous êtes
dans le style country track 100 go c'est
pas mal et on peut être dans des délires
rigole un peu de waris de tant d'entre
eux aussi voient là non c'est non mais
je vous jure les chérissait sous ne
tombait pas là dedans et ne vous dit pas
on va faire comme les autres 6,6 et il a
marqué 7 c'est horrible de s'en sortir
c'est horrible c'est tellement facile du
tout d'être dedans mais c'est tellement
horrible de s'en sortir
et donc voilà ne pas commencer pour en
sortir ça surtout